from the independent filmmakers I heard
you know two camps mostly people being
very positive about it and thinking that
this was yay finally some legitimate you
know productions are coming in and and
bringing awareness to what Kickstarter
is I have to say that before I came here
suddenly Kickstarter's being written
about in all these business marketing
blogs which I didn't realize really
hadn't happened before so it almost is
to me it's reaching out this mainstream
kind of audience because Kickstarter
does only fund creative projects so it
mainly was known you know in the
creative industries so it hadn't
occurred to me too much that people
outside of that warrant is aware I was
asked to recently did I think that we've
reached a saturation you know have we
hit everybody we've reached the pinnacle
as like oh no no man most people on the
street don't even know what Kickstarter
is so we're far from being saturated yes
as filmmakers we feel very saturated you
have tons of campaigns going on and
people asking you for money but if you
climb outside of the bubble to the
average Joe they do not know what
Kickstarter a crowdfunding the term
crowdfunding even means so so I don't
think that we're coming to this period
where people will stop giving because
they they're tapped out you know there's
too much going on then there's the other
camp that these projects are coming in
stealing money from us you know this was
supposed to be for the small guy the
startup guy who doesn't have any other
access to capital not these big guys who
can go out and snap their fingers I
don't think there's an unlimited amount
of funds I think that the tons of
charities in the world not to say the
Kickstarter is a charity but tons of of
nonprofit organizations exist in the
world and they all collect money from
the same group of people and nobody's
ever said we shouldn't have a heart
association because we already have a
Cancer Association and we already have a
women's group is that you know that kind
of thing that there's always room for
four other organizations that are
raising donations and so this is no
different from that do I think that it's
going to be possible for every filmmaker
to raise three or four million dollars
the Ray Veronica Mars not
right now no it depends on how long have
you been cultivating an audience you
know they had access one to broadcast
you know they had it they were a network
show they were only on for three years
they got canceled because they didn't
have high enough ratings the ratings
were not big enough to satisfy the
network but certainly big enough to
satisfy an audience that could help
raise four million dollars so I i think
that the downside of this is how it's
going to change the way creators think
about investors because I think that a
lot of times people still I hear people
still say this is investing crowd
investing no investing is you get repaid
with interest or some you know or you're
making money on the money you put in
this is donation this is very freeing to
a creator because they don't have to
concern paying back an investor and
protecting that investors money ideally
whatever they went out to the crowd to
say they wanted to do they stay true to
that they don't put it in their pocket
and go on vacation you know they would
really that would be the last time they
would be doing this but um you know
ideally or that they don't radically
change and go off from what they said
they were going to make that they they
do make that but the I don't understand
where the thought of it's more
legitimate for an artist to be deeply in
debt than it is for them to be debt-free
that that you know I've been hearing
that it's it's it's not as legitimate
it's it's detrimental for them to lock
out these corporations and these
investment firms and things like that it
then that's that's just astounding to me
you know that we encourage people to be
in debt more than we encourage them to
have freedom so I think that something
like Kickstarter is amazing for that
where does it lock people out banks you
know that used to loan money and get
interest off of these loans that's that
they're living is made from loaning
money out and so if you're not loaning
you're donating their kicked out of this
equation my thought banks have lots of
places to go to get money that the
tainment industries not their only
outlet so I'm not too fearful that
they're gonna all go belly-up and you
know not be able to find another place
to invest money and loan out money but I
think that for creators this is a huge
huge change huge opportunity but it
doesn't happen if you aren't willing to
cultivate some kind of audience you know
Rob Thomas I wouldn't say cultivated an
audience but he has a brand that has an
audience you know and they kind of
cultivate themselves they have fan sites
and they still get together whether
anybody from the show is participating
or not they have connection to each
other around this show not every show
has that not every film has that but
it's possible to stoke it it is possible
to grow that if you're willing to do it
and the longer you're doing it the
longer you're cultivating the more
likely you'll be able to raise more
money and and we've seen independent
filmmakers raising a couple hundred
thousand you know on these sites that's
nothing to sneeze at you know that's
that's a pretty good start if not you
know your whole budget can be raised and
not have to do repayment on that is
really amazing a really good opportunity
you